hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday January 13th 2018 what's going on
how I yeah how's it going I know I'm I
know I'm late I know I'm [ __ ] late
like your girlfriend after prom night oh
sorry for the bad joke there's gonna be
a lot of bad jokes on this this is old
Billy jet lag all right you know
remember buddy love and [ __ ] the
Nutty Professor you know it was a cooler
version of him I'm not cool on any level
so it just becomes worse versions of me
and today you're gonna be listening to
old Billy jet lag it's 5:40 1 in the
morning and I've been up for the last
two hours you know I don't know I'm on
yeah I'm back in LA I'm going going back
back to Billy Billy mol American Billy
again and I'm so glad to be back in a
country that likes Donald Trump you know
it's about time and I know there's a few
Hollywood people out here that are
trying to make it seem like there's a
bunch of people out there that don't
care for Donald Trump and it's just
simply not the case the guy has the
highest approval rating of any president
ever he has a higher approval rating
then then dictators where people are
afraid to say they don't like him this
is all true stuff he goes funny as he
will quote this podcast as a as a fan as
a fact to say that [ __ ] about himself
alright I thought I could do my podcast
with my mouth guardian I can't do it
hang on a second hang on a second all
right I'm back I know you guys are
thinking like Jesus Christ bill you're
50 years old you still have a mouth
guard you're still wearing a [ __ ]
retainer huh what are you going to your
sophomore semi-formal next week no I got
that Invisalign and I'm actually yeah I
listen to what the dentist says which is
you know all these people get Invisalign
they go through all the [ __ ] the pain
in the ass
[ __ ] of having this stuff and then when
the second they had done they give him
the mouth guard and they don't wear it
and then their teeth gradually just
become crooked again not me I paid for
this [ __ ] you let's like get your car
fixed and you go on you [ __ ]
sideswipe a tree why would you do that
you know you may not have a lot of
things in life but if you could have
nice straight teeth that gets you
through a lot of stuff
cops literally show up you know why did
you beat that woman I didn't beat her oh
look at his big shiny teeth hey
sweetheart what were you wearing that
made him do that that's what happens
that's how you get out of it
anyways I'm very very happy to come back
my oh my god my daughter gave me like
for the greatest hugs I've ever gotten
in my life when I got home it was
awesome
it's so weird you know when they're that
little they hug yet but then immediately
I want to go run and go do something
else you know yeah gosh she doesn't even
care then she kept coming back hugging
me before she'd go run back over to a
toy so it was pretty it was pretty
awesome
we finished the tour strong I don't even
know what the hell last day I talked to
you where the hell I was I don't know I
want to say I was on my way to Poland
was it Warsaw Berlin yeah Prague and
then Vienna and all of them were just
they were amazing Warsaw we went there
and I actually talked to burrs Eber as
he has a patreon page as do i and I did
a little quick half hour podcast with
him the only one of the only country met
on this trip was in Warsaw at our hotel
was a place that kind of looked like a
restaurant kind of looked like a cafe
and we went in there and we were
immediately told by the waiter that it
was a Chocolate Factory
he kept saying that like we were looking
we want to get something to eat and they
had all this chocolate [ __ ] there but
they also had sandwiches and stuff like
that so verse he says to him he goes
like hey so what would you say is your
uh what would you recommend what's the
best thing on and he goes What did he
say he said
chocolate to make it easy if I could if
I could sum it up chocolate like alright
we want some sandwiches is this a good
sandwich is there yeah yeah it's good
it's good it's been like that right then
he just kept having a [ __ ] comment on
everything that we were gonna do after
we ate he goes you want something else
you want something else and I go alright
you know maybe I'll get a hot chocolate
or something then he'd be like you sure
you have room it's like well if you
don't think I'm sick I'm too full after
what the [ __ ] I ain't why would you ask
me you [ __ ] skinny [ __ ] he was such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he was such a [ __ ] so then
I go up to I said you know I'll get some
hot chocolate he goes love each one we
have okay we were a truck ilat factory
it's like dude you're not a factory
you're not making the chocolate here
you're stupid skinny can't you know I am
this upset about it was cuz I kept
thinking like oh I'm being the ugly
American maybe I should be even nicer to
this guy and then nicer I was the more
of a [ __ ] he was and then in the end you
know when he was such a [ __ ] virzi got
mad furs he never gets mad I'll get mad
at [ __ ] that on that [ __ ] goddamn
peacock for some reason popped in my
head first it's trying to think pidgin
oh my god that guy is a temper he got
mad at a peacock even virzi was upset by
the end and then when I saw him getting
upset I realized how ridiculous was that
I was getting upset I just said Paul he
works in a Chocolate Factory
we're gonna go tell jokes and a [ __ ]
basketball arena in Warsaw and so then
we both laughed and the guy buddy take
it easy you know and I got to tell you
though the hot chocolate was the [ __ ]
they came over with little trio of them
one of them one of the hot chocolates
was white it's like white chocolate you
know which was which was uh you know
should have been my nickname when I
played basketball but I wasn't good so
that kid from Sacramento got it then
there was another one which is chocolate
chocolate and then was coffee chocolate
and I [ __ ] hate coffee so I gave that
to Paul the white chocolate was [ __ ]
bananas so the guy comes over and I'm
still trying to be friendly and I go all
the hot chocolate was delicious and he's
like really and I was like yeah this one
here and I pointing to
one that was whose [ __ ] amazing I
hadn't say mazing [ __ ] amazing I said
it was amazing he goes oh he must have
his sweet tooth okay alright you know he
was like so skinny you could have beaten
him with his own body you know what I
mean he was like he was like like a
nightstick with a [ __ ] head if
there's a chocolate flat oh then first
he went up to after his because he had
you know a burger or whatever the [ __ ]
you guys say can I get a piece of
chocolate the guys I guess you just want
one you're gonna go eat it so fast the
purse he's like I just want one you know
you know I mean all over there they fit
from World War two they have like the
you know the butcher of Baghdad or some
[ __ ] like that which was the Middle East
you know we would joke and he was the
[ __ ] of Warsaw
but as kunti as he was and as frustrated
as I was that I couldn't find a little
Polish flag you know that's what I do
when I go on the road I find those you
know those things that back in the day
people would sew into like a jacket I'm
not doing that
I'm gonna frame him I gotta have some
sort of frame where I can open and close
it where you know cuz it's a work in
progress where I'm gonna go and I just
want to keep adding to it and I couldn't
get the Polish flag because I took a
picture of the collage of them and put
it on Instagram a lot of people gave me
[ __ ] cuz I'd have the Polish flag the
German flag I already have a German flag
and I already been to Cologne before
that's why I didn't have that and I
didn't have the Polish flag because I
simply could not find a place a souvenir
place in the time allotted I went down
into the subway the odd the bound and
they literally had a Polish flag and
they had magnets and [ __ ] but they
didn't have the other one so I'm just
gonna order one off the internet today
today today today today so anyways then
we went out and did the show and it was
in like this [ __ ] basketball arena
and we it was it was [ __ ]
unbelievable the tour was great but
somewhat when it somewhere in Latvia and
then Budapest it just went to another
level and then the rest of the tour I I
you know I was in Budapest on stage
going like I think I would choose
special here and when I went to Warsaw
we were in this little basketball arena
type thing and they had a stool and that
this you know the seat was all [ __ ] up
and I just started making fun of it
going come on Warsaw come on you could
do better than that they had a great
sense of humor about themselves
I just you know I don't know it was just
one of those things I drift on the stool
and just just went from there then I
went to Berlin did a little shopping for
the ladies in my life you know try to
find him some sneakers and [ __ ] and it
was incredible you went there and they
had like this whole sort of like the
sack there's like the 5th Avenue of
Berlin and in the middle of all that I
should post the picture they had this
beautiful church that was built before
the time of World War two and it was all
bombed out like one of the spires was
busted off the top of it there was like
bullet holes and everything in it and
they kept it turned it into a store or
something like that but it was a
reminder of World War 2 and right next
to it was this ultra-modern building
that they were making it was really
really interesting and I would like to
go back there again soon and the next
time I do Germany and I go into Warsaw
as I mentioned before they never wanted
to go to a house which or anything like
that but now I kind of went down this
rabbit hole and I was looking up all of
that stuff and as much as you don't want
to go there to see that level of [ __ ]
evil it's kind of a good thing to be
reminded that you know an entire nation
of people can be talked into some [ __ ]
like that
[Music]
another thing that blew my mind was when
we were in Nuremberg and I don't still
want to make German yeah this is all
that it is because the food was [ __ ]
great the people were great but there is
that fascination so they have a field
there Zeppelin field I believe it's
called and it's not Led Zeppelin like
literally the guy who invented the
Zeppelin I think landed there and that's
where they had those giant Nazi [ __ ]
rallies way back in the day and that
place still exists they've taken down
all the pillars but you can just walk in
there and literally stand where Hitler
and all those [ __ ] lunatics stood and
I don't know I don't know what
it is everyone's like the beaches of
Normandy you just go there it's just a
beach but it's a really like [ __ ]
emotional thing when you go there like
Jesus Christ and then you see like what
was stopped how great that is but now
you see where the [ __ ] that we've ended
up and it's just really you know human
beings where we're you know we're kind
of like at the Jaguar in the in the
other Jaguar however you say it mid 80s
Jaguar you know it's a great [ __ ] car
you know it's beautiful and all of that
but it [ __ ] breaks down all the time
it always needs to be fixed him and when
I was teasing him over in Germany about
that [ __ ] I was quick to tell them that
we've my country has done everything
that you guys have done we just [ __ ]
it just wasn't filmed you know what I'm
saying which is weird cuz I go when I go
over to Germany and [ __ ] I was taught
about this how I sit there and think
like oh my god this is like you know
Hitler he gave a speech here and there
was a concentration camp over there but
when you know I'm down south I don't
think when I'm at a Waffle House that
maybe this wood used to be a plantation
and someone got [ __ ] beaten to death
there or they were running away from
their slave man I never think of that
[ __ ] but this is where Native Americans
were and they were just sort of hanging
out we [ __ ] came in and murdered all
of them oh isn't this a fun podcast so
anyways after Berlin we then went down
to the Czech Republic and I performed in
this theater that was basically where
they would have all the the the the
Communists rallies you know and
communism is yet another thing that gets
a bad rap communism gets a boat doesn't
work don't logo it's like none of them
work none of them work because they work
in theory in theory hey man everybody
has the same stuff man and everybody
lives community that works if everybody
buys in but they don't because there's
always concert the top that want [ __ ]
more and then there's also people who
think well you know if there's no reward
for [ __ ] working harder than somebody
else I'm just going to coast
[ __ ] right and then you have capitalism
hey whoever's the [ __ ] best [ __ ]
but bad but they're they're gonna
[ __ ] getting its that's not how it
works
it's not how it works whoever's the best
whatever will now be absorbed by a
corporation or crushed is how it works
and I don't know if you think it's
[ __ ] working you're not paying
attention to our bottom line right now
this country is bankrupt and has been
bankrupt since [ __ ] 2008 as far as I
can tell and everybody's just ignoring
it I mean Jesus Christ Clemson won the
national championship they go to the
White House and they got [ __ ]
Domino's and Wendy's and everybody's
blaming Donald Trump like what kind of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] does that and they're
blaming this shutdown it's like guys we
are bankrupt okay this is what poor
people eat they eat fast food all right
I'm sorry that's a wake-up call - where
the [ __ ] we're at right now but we are
[ __ ] bankrupt and I don't agree with
a lot of [ __ ] that Trump's doing but if
that guy can somehow get us out of these
[ __ ] wars so we can begin to try and
figure out how to pay him back I mean I
don't I don't know yeah I don't get like
whatever I mean I know what the [ __ ]
were doing over there everybody knows
what the [ __ ] we're doing over there
then everybody knows what we're saying
that we're doing over there and it's two
completely [ __ ] different things
anyways I don't want to get on a whole
[ __ ] thing because I don't pay
attention to enough of it but it seems
to me that we are [ __ ] we spent a
trillion dollars to stop 3,500 [ __ ]
jerk-offs is what we're doing now on a
jungle-gym that don't have a plane or a
[ __ ] boat and we've gone bankrupt
doing that and like half a dozen
corporations made a zillion dollars off
of it and continued to try and keep us
over there because they also own media
so no-one is hopefully people will begin
to talk about this [ __ ] because that I
know this doesn't sound patriotic
because now patriotism is just support
the troops like to oppose the troops you
know and if you know if you don't
support the troops get the [ __ ] out of
the country it's like
okay I support the troops but can I
logically talk financially
what the [ __ ] we've done so that our
kids our kids kids our kids kids kids
kids kids all the way down the line
won't still be paying for this [ __ ]
thing and you know what I am open to
discussion here let's let's [ __ ] open
this up we got the call we got the
[ __ ] lines open can somebody please
explain to me financially how we're
gonna get out from underneath us
I did feel good when I was in Germany
that they were going to switch to
renewable energy which i think is the
solution to middle eastern terrorism
because it seems all the oil money that
they make off of oil is funneled through
the mosque and then financed to these
groups that we don't like that want to
kill us so if we stop buying their oil
they don't have any money
and then they don't even have a jungle
gym is that is that to say I'm sure
that's too simple but I do this a lot
I say ignorant [ __ ] and then people
straighten me out so all I ask is that
if you think I'm way off base and right
now you're screaming at your [ __ ]
windshield calm the [ __ ] down and just
explain to me how off space I am and I
will listen I can be swayed I don't have
confidence in my opinion I deliver it
with confidence but in the back of my
head there's always that voice being a
pill you don't read you know read books
alright so we went to we went to Prague
and we we performed at this place where
I imagine Brezhnev or Gorbachev had
spoke at and I got such a kick out of
being in there as far as like all the
[ __ ] talk and that must have been done
about the United States of America and I
was sort of riffing imitating them the
comrade they are all FET over there they
have FET and they [ __ ] their six
sisters all that [ __ ] and then I was
there telling my dick jokes but that
crowd was [ __ ] unbelievable and they
just rolled with everything and I gotta
be honest with you I haven't felt that
much I haven't had that much fun on
[ __ ] stage in forever because of
what's going on with stand-up comedy I
actually was able to get away I kept
tagging all of my jokes going and if I
said that in a
erricka my career would be over and they
all laughed they all laughed you know so
once again as I stated in my last
podcast comedians okay we're you know we
need to stick up for each other we don't
need to be taking each other down about
material there's literally comedians
going online tweeting about people's
material and saying maybe they shouldn't
they're everybody's comedians are
turning into Al Gore's wife you know
when she used to tack heavy metal like I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on but
for the love of God shut up
use your head cuz you're chopping your
own [ __ ] head off
eventually that [ __ ] is though the
waters gonna rise up around your ankles
you can eventually you're gonna drown in
the [ __ ] that you're creating here
so anyways we were over there had a
great show we found a cigar bar smoked a
wonderful part aigis party guests
however the [ __ ] you say tomato tomahto
and then we went back to the hotel room
we like can you imagine if the [ __ ] in
Kansas City Colts game was on and they
had this sports channel seven they're
over there and we got it and we [ __ ]
lost our minds and it like you know
midnight over there we were watching the
second third and fourth quarter no we
got we watched the second half so we
kind of missed all the scoring and I
would say this I will say this for the
Patriots game and the Chiefs game both
of those defenses that you saw the
Patriots defense and the Chiefs defense
everyone say wow what's going on these
guys really figured something out what
you were seeing there was two teams that
were just totally out coaching the other
team they had a game plan that worked
and the other team could not adjust to
it all right
the Chiefs defense is not as good as it
looked the Patriots defense is not as
good as it looked against the Colts
that's what I took away from both of
those [ __ ] games so I'm an old-school
guy I know that the game has played a
different way now when you go for
two-point conversions with an entire
[ __ ] quarter left I know it's all
about offense but I still believe
that defense wins Super Bowls despite
last year's Super Bowl you know if you
really look at it all you know they only
needed to make one defensive play one
big defensive play was made and that
changed the game so I don't know I am
definitely skeptical as to whether the
Patriots or the Chiefs can win the Super
Bowl with their defenses
having said that I'm very excited for
this matchup the rematch and the
Patriots have to go into Arrowhead after
already beating the Kansas City Chiefs
by the skin of our teeth letting up 40
41 points was it 44 40 or something like
that even though we beat them last time
it was by no means impressive
defensively you know which is why you
know we beat the chargers somebody wrote
they had this hilarious tweet where they
said you know it's poor chargers you
know it's so difficult to find a
quarterback that can beat Tom Brady and
then they had a picture of
Eli Manning when he first got drafted by
the charges holding up the jerseys and
then of course all these other fans
rather than getting the joke that the
joke was making fun of the Chargers
decision to get rid of Eli Manning
forget about Drew Brees someone's world
um and then showed a picture of Nick
Foles and it's like they weren't talking
about the Eagles and that that is
something that does bug me though as a
Patriots fan that people are trying to
say Nick Foles beat Tom Brady he didn't
he beat the [ __ ] Patriots defense all
right because if you look them at the
Patriots you know Brady versus foals
Brady only threw I mean Foles only threw
for like 300 something yards Brady threw
for over 500 [ __ ] yards and lost
[ __ ] ridiculous so having said that
maybe the Patriots in the Chiefs maybe
one of them could win at the Super Bowl
but my pick has been the [ __ ] New
Orleans Saints which I was really
nervous about when they were down 14 to
nothing and I love Nick Foles I [ __ ]
love that guy that guy
he plays you know he's one of those like
he like the bigger the game is the
better that guy plays and the [ __ ]
way that that that organization keeps
putting him on the [ __ ] bench because
they got so much money invested I guess
in carson wentz not saying that that
guy's bad cuz he did great but you know
a lot of people would demand a trade or
something like that he just [ __ ] sits
there and it's like I when do you need
me and when you do I'm gonna go in and
crush it so I don't know it was kind of
funny though watching Eagle fans all
patting themselves on the back about how
great they are because they weren't
sending death threats to that wide
receiver who had the ball go through his
his hands which is a great thing and it
was impressive that they didn't do that
but they got a little they got a little
ahead of themselves about how great they
are they kind of forget that they have a
jail in their Stadium they kind of
forget that an entire row of Eagle fans
thinks nothing of beating up a father
who's there with his child because he
has the different Jersey on or spitting
on him or puking on him a throwing [ __ ]
just you know take it down a little bit
Eagles fans are such [ __ ] they
actually think they're good people for
the simple fact that they didn't send a
death threat you know you guys sound
like you sound like feminist right now
the only thing you didn't do is call
yourself brave he dropped the ball and
we didn't send death threats were so
brave we're such were warriors anyways
sorry to Eagle nation tough [ __ ] loss
I was loving what even though you were
gonna [ __ ] up my pic I was loving what
you guys were doing when it was 14 to
nothing and you know you defended Super
Bowl champions and I felt you weren't
getting your respect the same way I
can't say the Patriots deserve respect
this year we've taken some brutal losses
but it was in the back of my head I was
kind of hoping that the Patriots and
Eagles would both make it to the
Superbowl again just to shut all these
[ __ ] people up but we shall see all
right having said that
we have to go in to Arrowhead Stadium
the loudest fans in the league they
don't need a stadium that is
architectural II designed to make them
sound louder than they really are they
are [ __ ] loud as [ __ ] they are so
[ __ ] sick of the Patriots they always
beat us you know early in the season or
give us a good game and every year it's
like this is the year it's gonna be over
I told you that guy that guy I saw and I
was in that sports bar in New York City
and that guy was just screaming this is
it's over this is what it is now and he
was losing his [ __ ] about wanting to
beat the Patriots who's a Chiefs fan and
he just kept yelling sporadically and
then it just became non-stop yelling
until he was tapped on the shoulder
asked to go he got up peacefully put his
coat on and continued to scream at the
TV right out into public and I was just
sitting there being like wow man that's
how much people hate the Patriots and
also I've been there as you know what
bat when an old-school Patriots fans
certainly a Red Sox fan and a Bruins fan
when we couldn't beat the Canadiens and
all of that [ __ ] so I kind of knew what
that guy was going for so it's gonna be
a weird game where I want to see the
Patriots win obviously but if the Chiefs
go to the Super Bowl that'll be really
really [ __ ] cool I mean they have not
been there since [ __ ] Super Bowl for
everybody 67 68 69 1970 64 toss power
trap right Hank Stram way to [ __ ] back
then when they played played the Vikings
Super Bowl for what are we up to now
Super Bowl 50 something I've even lost
track and I'm a [ __ ] nerd about this
[ __ ] so with that all in the Rams the
Rams beat the Cowboys I missed that game
and then I missed the I missed another
game I forgot what the other no I think
I saw both AFC games I saw I saw parts
of three or four of them but now I am
back back but you know what's you know
what's hilarious is I have a birthday
party you have to go to four
special person my own daughter coming up
this week so I'm gonna be missing some
of the playoffs cuz old daddy makes the
makeup birthday cake from scratch every
year that's what I'm gonna do and I got
to do that you know you got to do [ __ ]
like that anyways alright so I took a
bunch of saunas when I was over there in
Europe and oh I didn't even talk about
the cities by the way I even talked
about Vienna then I go to Vienna and
Vienna had like this incredible [ __ ]
theater and this club owner to the club
owners they were just the nicest people
ever and they were feeding us like an
Italian grandmother like I even know
what that is the waivers II always
described it just would not say no just
kept bringing out you know vino
schnitzel and and then all these
desserts you know I love our desserts
over there's like a tray of cheese or
like something sugary and it was just it
was unbelievable I think I consumed like
3000 calories but it's European calories
so it's not like the poison over here so
I woke up the next day being like how am
I not fatter oh that's right I got out
from under my own food supply so I want
to thank them to Prague I got to Prague
and Budapest
a lot of Americans sleep on those cities
absolutely gorgeous like I would say
Prague is like the Paris of the Midwest
of Europe as far as my little you know I
didn't get to see too much of it but
just you know driving from the airport
looking at it was like both of those
cities were we're breathtaking and my
stupid computer keeps shutting down here
anyways
I watched the rest of Papillon - the
original one when I came back when I
flew back man that was [ __ ]
incredible and then I watched this
two-hour documentary which I forget what
it was called
about the CrossFit championships and it
mainly focused on the women and stuff
like that and you know what like I said
earlier where I could be wrong about our
our foreign policy I think I was wrong
about
CrossFit watching what those people were
able to do physically but as an old man
watching it I'm just going like I don't
know how long these people's bodies are
gonna last doing that follow those
[ __ ] squats and all of that [ __ ] with
you all I was all I was thinking knees
and shoulders knees and shoulders you
need those for the rest of your life
however I think stem-cell research is
going to get to the point where
everyone's you know all that religious
[ __ ] is gonna go by the wayside to just
have the [ __ ] knees and shoulders of
an 18 year old when you're 60 I'm
telling you right now there is gonna be
some [ __ ] jacked older people in the
future I got a buddy of mine he had a
torn rotator cuff and he got that [ __ ]
injected in there and he doesn't even
have scar tissue it's [ __ ] crazy
do I sound like a crazy person right now
I'm talking about foreign policy and
[ __ ] stem-cell research right this is
this is all he's all over the [ __ ]
map all right let me do a couple of
reads and then I'm gonna tell you what
was like to take a sauna in Germany all
right okay butcher box butcher blocks
delivers healthy 100% grass-fed
grass-finished beef free-range orange
chicken and had the top-shelf heritage
bread pork all right this is pure bred
pigs that you can trace the bloodline
back to Europe all right [ __ ] Rudolf
Hess would hate this [ __ ] poor the
incredible quality of butcher boy you
know I didn't root oh I didn't know that
Rudolf Hess he left before all the evil
evil [ __ ] went down he was there for the
beginning of the evil like the gameplan
of it but before the final solution was
was even put into place he [ __ ] got on
a plane and left they went to Scotland
and there's all this [ __ ] about whether
Hitler knew he was gonna do it or if he
deserted he went up there and tried to
make peace with England and Winston
Churchill it was like no we're not
making peace go [ __ ] yourself and arrest
this [ __ ] and then he spent the rest of
his life in jail
and then killed himself allegedly at 93
where some people thought that he was uh
he was strangled you know there's always
people you know whatever but anyways one
of the great quotes of all time when
Rudolph has got in a plane and flew up
to Scotland in the middle of the war to
try and make peace Hitler's quote quote
about Rudolf Hess was that guy's insane
I mean that's just one of the greatest
[ __ ] quotes ever Adolf Hitler called
somebody insane that goes back to when I
first started in this business it was
right around the time when my favorite
drummers of all time Steven Adler got
kicked out of guns and roses and their
thing was yeah he's doing too many drugs
and every comic had that joke how many
how much drugs are you doing that the
other members of Guns and Roses go yeah
we got to get rid of this guy he's
partying too much that was you know that
that was the Guns N'Roses version of
when Hitler said eight Rudolf Hess was
insane all right all right back to put
your bucks everybody the incredible
quality of butcher box meat starts with
the commitment to start with the
commitment to raising animals humanely
and free of antibiotics and hormones
before they kill them cook with PETA
peace of mind of knowing you're eating
healthy high quality meat each box comes
with least 8 to 11 pounds of meats which
is enough for 24 individual size meals
if you happen you know if you eat like
that guy in 7 who ended up face down in
his SpaghettiOs I mean you're gonna
you're gonna go through that [ __ ] in a
week you can choose from five different
box types all beef beef and chicken beef
and pork mix box a custom box which lets
you choose your own cuts my favorite box
cut is I'm supposed to say I would say
I'd have to go beef and pork or maybe I
go mix box by like custom box too you
know I like a custom car I don't know
I don't know because they just keep
sending me the [ __ ] for free cuz they're
liking the way I'm reading this stuff
anyway so now we're noun seing our new
brand of protein what they find a new
animal wild alaskan salmon butcher box
sources sources they're pure sustainably
harvested salmon from Bristol Bay Alaska
unlike any salmon you'll find in your
local store literally is its red color
means that this salmon is as fresh and
nutrient rich as it gets for $20 off
your first box and two pounds of fries
salmon go to butcher box calm / burn
enter BER B you are ours that's butcher
box com enter BER and enter birth sorry
you know it's funny I've got I got so
sick of watching comedians attacking
other comedians on Twitter and and
people screaming about Trump that I
found somehow I found this place where
you could like maybe follow some
different things on Twitter so I decided
to go into the science world like this
will fascinate me I have such a poor
science background let me [ __ ] read
up on this [ __ ] right and all it did was
talk about how we're destroying the
environment and it was even more
depressing than listening to [ __ ]
morons yelling about politics as I on
this politics politics on this podcast
gave you my solution for solving the
Middle East problems I mean how
hypocritical am I so anyways I went on
there and I found out some snail just
the last one they called him George out
in Hawaii has now died and evidently
those things are gonna go extinct
stamps.com everybody
stamps.com is the faster and more
convenient way to get postage simply use
your computer to print official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it and the mail carrier picks it up no
more lugging mail to the post office no
more hassles man with stamps calm you
get discounted postage rates that you
can't even get at the post office not to
mention it's a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters and
there's no equipment to leased and no
long-term commitments I use stamps calm
to send out all my posters Christmas
gifts it's great it's great and right
now
and I'm a [ __ ] if I can figure it out
so can you and right now you too can
enjoy stand stop the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale so start the new year off
right go to Stan's comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur that stamps comm enter
bur alright before I do the reeds this
week I took a sauna when I was in
Germany and evidently they I heard that
they were naked they go into those
saunas naked and it's co-ed so I asked
virzi if he wanted to go down to the
sauna he said yes and then I texted him
he must have fell asleep so I said [ __ ]
it I went down I worked out got a great
workout in and then I went to go into
the Sun and there was nobody in there
and the old me I like the steam now I
really like the dry sauna cuz I can get
way hotter
you know Joe Rogan converted me right so
I go in there and I went in there like
an American I had my slippers on I had
my towel on and all of that [ __ ] and
then all of a sudden this dude comes
walking and he has a towel on oh my god
thank God thank God it's Berlin okay
it's brilliant okay this is like their
New York City so everybody's gonna act
accordingly and then he just immediately
takes his towel off and I'm like what
the [ __ ] is any lays and then lays down
yeah what he did was he put his outside
leg the leg close to me he put it up so
he was sort of covering his junk slashed
looked like he was getting ready to do
recreate the Burt Reynolds Playgirl
centerfold right so anyways and I know
this is gonna be the [ __ ] Photoshop
so I'm sitting there like that what the
[ __ ] all right whatever one naked dude
who gives a [ __ ] right and then all of a
sudden another guy comes in this guy
comes in he doesn't have his towel on
he's just holding his towel in front of
his junk then he goes in like it was
shaped like a horseshoe you know like
the old [ __ ] Denver Broncos stadium
back in the day so I'm on one side of
the horseshoe I'm unlike the visitors
side then the first naked dude is on the
[ __ ] home side and then this naked
guy comes in and he lays down the same
way same Playgirl [ __ ] thing with the
outside leg up
he's sitting in the end zone seats
alright and I'm like Jesus [ __ ] Christ
so now I'm laughing cuz all I'm thinking
is I'm gonna tell versi because at this
point it's just naked guys and just
naked guys it's just funny I stupid my
act a naked man is either funny or scary
right
if you're at a football game and a naked
guy jumps out of the crowd and runs
across the field you're laughing your
ass off if you're walking home late at
night then naked guy jumps out of the
[ __ ] bushes it's one of the scariest
things ever so this was just funny I'm
in a gym there's all kinds of people
around or whatever even though it's just
the three of us in there but you know I
can just get up walk out the [ __ ]
door there's no danger here there's two
naked guys it's [ __ ] hilarious
so I'm looking down at the floor and all
I'm thinking about is I can't wait to
tell versions of this [ __ ] story
they're both laying here like [ __ ]
twin Burt Reynolds and I'm sitting there
with my slippers on and my towel you
know I don't know so anyways and then
all of a sudden the door opens again and
now a woman comes walking in and I'm
looking I kind of look at the guys I got
are gonna cover themselves up and they
don't and then she comes in and just
takes her [ __ ] towel off just like
and then she sits down in the end zone
seats
alright so above her in the upper deck
is this naked guy to her left is the
other naked guy she's naked and now she
looks over at me and I got a towel on
and slippers so now I'm looking like the
weirdo now I'm the [ __ ] perfect like
woo this [ __ ] guy we're all getting
naked why are you sitting over there
right so now I'm like well I gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here and just as I said
that the dude in the home seat he stands
up and he's going to walk out and I'm
like alright perfect now he's gonna use
the shower I'm just gonna wait the
Eastown with the shower then I'm gonna
[ __ ] walk out so that's exactly what
happens I walk out but when I walk out
what I forgot to mention was they had
like you know those ice baths that like
NFL players go to get into they had
something like that there wasn't ice it
was just like it was a tank he climbed
up like six steps and then climbed down
into this thing and it was freezing
[ __ ] cold right after the sauna right
and just closes up all you
it gets rid of all the [ __ ] toxins
and all of that and all the [ __ ] washes
off you granted everybody else is using
it so it's probably [ __ ] gross in a
some level I have no idea maybe because
it's so cold it kills this [ __ ] I don't
know what so I wanted to use it but
there was no way I was going to use it
because I had to get up to the top of it
and take my towel off and be standing up
there with my [ __ ] man who had
twisted in the breeze before I went down
into the [ __ ] Arctic water but when I
came out there was nobody there so I was
like I got it I gotta try it
so I [ __ ] scampered up the ladder
quickly took my towel off and then went
down into it I was like [ __ ] it was
freezing cold went all the way up to
like my neck and wanted to stay there
for a minute but probably only stayed
there for like 15 seconds it was enough
for me
but plus also I knew other people were
going to come in I didn't want to come
crawling out of there completely naked
like [ __ ] Jason Alexander now with my
[ __ ] junk all pulled up into me right
so the other dudes in the shower I can
hear him so now I go to get out of this
[ __ ] thing I get my towel on and
everything and I feel [ __ ] amazing to
go from that heat to that cold now I'm
gonna go into the shower it was [ __ ]
amazing so I get out of the shower now
all I want to do is tell virzi the
[ __ ] story and be like dude even a
chick came and this is [ __ ] nuts and
I reach into my robe and I can't find my
key to my locker and like where the [ __ ]
is it that I drop it
with and I'm looking all around and I
was and last time I remembered having it
I was holding it in my hand when I was
in the sauna because I didn't want to
leave it in the pocket of my robe for
some reason I didn't see like the band
that you could put it around your wrist
I just didn't you know I'm an idiot and
I saw I was just holding on to it and I
suddenly realized that it was still in
the [ __ ] sauna so now I have to go
back into the sauna so I go back in
there with my head down with my [ __ ]
slippers on and my towel on and I go
back in there and the naked woman is now
laying down sideways facing the door
okay laying down where I was sitting and
I'm like I can't go over there with my
towel on being like hey I'm just looking
for my keys all right there sweetheart I
felt like a [ __ ] weirdo so now I sat
down she's sitting on the [ __ ]
visitor side now I'm on the home side or
whatever I might have [ __ ] up these
things you know what I mean I'm sitting
on the opposite side that I was sitting
on and now I'm just sitting there going
all right well she was she's been in
here for like ten minutes she's gonna
[ __ ] leave soon and when she does I'm
gonna look for my keys and she just
won't leave she won't leave and then
finally I just have to get up because
I'm dying cuz this is my second trip and
I find when I say I'm sorry I think I
left my key over here and she's like oh
I didn't see it and she's like sitting
up like [ __ ] naked right so now I go
back over and I just [ __ ] sit down I
know I [ __ ] up the story I'm sitting
down there going what the [ __ ] do I do
now because I'm dying a heat and then
all of a sudden this couple comes
walking in and then they both get naked
so now there's two naked women a naked
dude and then me all covered up and at
this point now I feel like a [ __ ]
weirdo so I'm like well [ __ ] it I'm in
Germany so now I take my towel off and
I'm just sitting there cracking up
[ __ ] laughing like you know that you
just look down and you just you know
what it's like I'm gonna laugh my ass
off but nobody's gonna know so you don't
make a sound
and you don't change your face you just
have your mouth open and you're just
kind of going like I was literally doing
that while I was so [ __ ] hot I could
feel my heartbeat in my ears so at some
point it just got so hot and she wasn't
leaving and it she was like a pro so I
finally just got up and I just sort of
had my towel cover myself I go I'm sorry
I think I left my key over and she goes
I did not see at the boba and I go
alright so then I went back and I sat
down that's what I did that's when I sat
down and then she got up and I was like
still I go it's got to be underneath her
or something so I waited for her to
leave i toughed it out and then I walk
over there and I'm feeling around on the
[ __ ] seats and
and it's just not there and they have
the slats and I'm like it probably fell
down in between it now I'm gonna have to
walk out with just my towel and robe on
go back to the front desk pay the fee
and all of this [ __ ] so now I walk out
of the sauna I'm [ __ ] almost passing
out and to my left and my peripheral I
see that woman again naked at the top of
the [ __ ] ladder to go into the ice
bath I'm like jesus [ __ ] christ I got
to get out of here right and as I'm
walking away you know what I do besides
I hear her yelling over to somebody and
I'm like I know she's not talking to me
and then she just goes then she switches
to English and she goes did you find
your key and I kind of half turned but
didn't look at her and I go no no I
didn't and then she goes is this it and
I realized I had that's where I left it
when I scampered up the ladder to go
there I left it at the top you guys but
I go oh yeah it is
and then she stays at the top of the
ladder and just you know kind of hands
it and I walk over and literally her
vagina is above me and I kind of reach
up like looking but not looking just go
danke Schoen and I was so [ __ ] up I
didn't even take a shower I just walked
out and I went to the locker room and I
went in there and I was like pouring
sweat and everyone was looking at me
like well why didn't he shower off he's
already like the tomato anyways and then
I just I put my [ __ ] back on and then
that there you go that's my German sauna
story but I have I got it I do have to
tell you this though if you're
completely naked in a sauna it's even
better it is even better it's [ __ ]
weird but you only can do it in a place
if everybody's naked then it isn't weird
it isn't weird and if you're worried
that you're gonna get a stiffy because
there's a naked woman in there there's
also net other naked men in there so it
neutralizes it not to mention it's hot
as [ __ ] like I don't think anybody has
ever [ __ ] in one of those hot naked
you know
not naked the hot yoga class what they
call that the Bikram yoga like you can
barely survive the [ __ ] somebody is
the last thing on your mind when you're
sitting in like a hundred and eighty
degree heat but anyways there's my that
was my sauna story it was hilarious I
was worried that my junk was gonna look
too small when I got out of the ice bath
and I was worried that I was gonna
[ __ ] salute the Germans when I was in
the sauna but I would you know if a
naked woman walked in but it didn't I
just felt like a [ __ ] creep
so anyways and that's why you travel the
world everybody to get stories like that
alright anyways alright follow-up should
girl have paid for dinner now this
became something on reddit where I was
reading this thing where this guy it the
way I read it and the way I understood
it now granted I was jet lag flying
around Europe I thought he was saying
that he took his girlfriend out for a
birthday dinner with his parents and
when the bill came she had to pay for
her meal so she was upset about that and
then now he invited to her another
family gathering and she made some
flippant comment asking him she'd have
to pay for the gas to get there and I
sided with her going through you can't
make somebody pay for their birthday
meal so anyways somebody I read it said
Billy got a little confused with that
email about the birthday dinner the
boyfriend's family weren't expecting the
girlfriend to pay for her own birthday
dinner they were expecting her to pay
for her own meal at his birthday dinner
oh okay the email said this I think he
was just a little bit too jet-lagged all
right well my mistake it's a little
spoiled for her to get that dinner and
instantly expect to go to that dinner
and instantly expect her meal be paid
for I wouldn't really say I come from a
family of means but we're not broke and
when I've gone out for dinner for my
birthday my folks have always been happy
to pay however my partner never just
assumed this it's rude to I agree with
that but have
said that I would also pay I would make
my girlfriend pay for the meal even if
you seek if you're secretly hoping
someone else pays for your meal when
it's not a special occasion celebrating
something for you
just don't sit there and assume the text
message asking if she expected to pay
for own gas is astounding in its level
of rudeness - I don't think that that's
rude because I think that's that's her
reacting to being upset that she was
made to pay for her own meal uh yeah and
then I actually see the boyfriends point
if that's exactly if that's how it was
worded I mean I can I understand why she
assumed that they would have taken care
of both of them because it was his
birthday it was a special occasion and
she's also a guest
she's company you know what I mean I
understand that that makes sense to me
so I actually I still side with the with
the woman on this one I kind of get it
like if my parents didn't pick up for my
wife's meal I would have paid for it
I don't know anyways anyways it's not
it's not remotely spoiled for the girl
to assume that the meal was paid for I
am on her side 100% I can't remember a
single time growing up where I was
invited out to dinner with a friend's
family and I was expected to pay for my
own meal yeah it's one of those things
if you're going out as a couple like two
couples are going out then you split it
anyways now that I am an adult with kids
of my own I would be incredibly
embarrassed to ask my son's girlfriend
to pay for own meal at his birthday I am
I agree with that hundred percent now
the text message was passive-aggressive
but I think the meal thing and the
boyfriends reaction to it was so
egregious that I don't have a problem
with it
I don't either I don't either I side
with them too anyways another one I'm
sorry supposed to say anyway I like
saying anyways I used the Waze app why
can't I say anyways I cannot believe
anyone doesn't have the same answer as
you haha Jesus Christ where did these
animals grow up I would die of
embarrassment if I was at a restaurant
my with my family and my girlfriend and
my girlfriend and my dad asked
turf for money yeah I agree with you you
know I just think that maybe we're
braver maybe we're the Warriors social
justice warriors hey you know it's great
about doing this podcast this early is
my daughter's not gonna be up for like
another hour so I get to hang all
morning with them um I bought her all
these cool sneakers when I was over
there she's like good until she's like
three or four years old cuz I got the
size wrong the size I was told to get I
thought what she was that size now and
turns out that that was you know the
next size up so I got two sizes and
three sizes up but they're all cool
sneakers
well they're all cool sneakers that I
got when I was altar in Germany jet lag
hey Billy numbnuts try valerian tea to
help reset your sleep cycle while
traveling it also helps take the edge
off at the end of the day when the
whiskey blankie is not an option VLAN ky
is not an option works for me I will
definitely do that because I'm 52 days
in and not drinking and had I not done
that thrash I would actually look good
people were taking pictures of me I was
like I look [ __ ] horrible like just
lack of sleep that's all we did for 10
days straight fly in go to the hotel go
do a show or two go back to the hotel
sleep try to go to sleep and then you'd
have to get up at 7 to take a train or
something like that and the younger me I
would have looked fresh as a daisy if I
wasn't drinking but I was looking for
those pictures I was like I might as
well been doing [ __ ] meth out here I
will try that I actually got some
melatonin when I was over there that
everybody says it's all-natural but I
got to tell you it makes you feel a
little buzzed I don't know I don't know
about that [ __ ] but it definitely helped
me go to sleep
fat fellows speaking here hello mr.
bender bender overi bender over bill I
don't know what that means I am 19 years
old five seven on a good day in 320
pounds
right dude you got to do something about
that thank God you got a young heart but
you will not be 5/7 you know in your 60s
at 320 pounds and I'm not a doctor and I
know this is a fact anyways I just
wanted to ask you as a heavy fellow who
tries very hard to be kind and courteous
to those around him how can I be better
I purposely avoid planes and public
transportation because I understand how
uncomfortable it must be for others to
even be around me it is very difficult
because I have an irrational fear of
driving and there are no taxi or uber
services in my area I legitimately tried
to keep to myself for example in a
grocery store if I have to pass someone
who was shopping I apologize simply
because I block half the aisle most of
the time folks are very kind in short
mr. Burke how can I be better to other
folks who are less girthy thank you for
your time what I got out of that sir is
I think that you need to come out of
your shell and I probably maybe go get
some therapy and maybe part of your
reason for eating and all of that type
of stuff is there there seems to be a
little bit of self-loathing going on
here and God knows I was the king of
that it just didn't manifest itself into
overeating it manifested itself in the
other [ __ ] that I'm still trying to work
out but maybe if you start going to
therapy you start reading up on
nutrition and I got to tell you do it a
few 5-7 320 pounds like I mean I would
think that you'd be able to drop a lot
of weight if you just started eating
right because you obviously don't need
all of that on you and then I think as
you learn about yourself in therapy and
as you start to drop weight you're gonna
come out of your shelf because you're
not going to have to have those feelings
that your being you know you're just
like a sensitive person the fact that
you actually care is you have you're an
empathetic person and a lot of times
people who are really empathetic can get
in their heads
and can get really like I just think you
know I feel like that made me sad
reading that so I don't want you walking
around being sad you're in the prime of
your life like and what's great is the
fact that you're 5-7 320 pounds you have
a great before picture all right so you
got that checked off your bucket list
now you can you can turn this whole
[ __ ] thing around and and you're so
young that you got your whole life ahead
of you you can just turn that around
find out what I would literally go to
therapy and just put it all out on the
[ __ ] table you know what you feel
your problem is what you're afraid of
what makes you cry and all of that [ __ ]
and then I would I would just start
literally marching towards getting in
shape it'll help your [ __ ] confidence
and then what's great is is when you
become a good-looking guy that's out
there [ __ ] slaying it and the ladies
are loving you you know you've had the
experience of being 5 7 3 20 so you
won't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] I remember
one time I was on a plane a long long
long [ __ ] time ago like 15 years ago
and I was sitting next to this woman who
was a [ __ ] knockout an absolute
knockout and I sat down next to her and
she was just like hey how you doing and
I was like good I think you know women
who look that good don't aren't like
that you know and it's not just because
you know there's stuck up it's because
when they're that good-looking if they
even remotely make eye contact with
another man they're now gonna have to
deal with them hitting on him you know
so she was totally open was so [ __ ]
cool and we're just shootin the [ __ ] she
was talk to me like she was like a
widget salesman instead of like a
[ __ ] 10 and then the end I finally
had a say I'm gonna be honest yeah I've
never I've never been around a woman as
good-looking as you that was like this
outgoing you had your personnel your
personnel he's amazing and she laughed
she goes uh-huh she goes I used to be
fat so I'm sure you already already got
the personality so you know what you are
you're like a great barn-find in in like
the automotive industry I'm not calling
you a [ __ ] cow I'm saying like you
know when they go
the barns they'll find this great old
car that they then restore and everybody
[ __ ] loves it so there you go restore
yourself sir that's what I would do and
and I believe in you I think you can do
it just just put your mind to it but I
think you just got to figure out why
you're you know why you are the way you
are cuz I know just being courteous and
empathetic isn't all you who you are you
got [ __ ] to say you got hopes you got
dreams you want to find love so let's go
let's get after it get your ass out
there all right girlfriend won't lose
weight it's all about weight this this
week here dear Billie not so fat thank
you I'll take that that's exactly what I
am I'm not so fat but I definitely had a
little too much of the interstate so
yeah my girlfriend and I have been
dating for three years going on four and
I'm starting to have different feelings
towards her because of her eating habits
and the way she takes care of herself
since I met her several years ago she
kind of had a weight thing that was
noticeable you know what I just [ __ ]
flaked reading this I got to start over
again I was just thinking how amazing it
is that Joe Rogan has Mike Tyson on his
podcast and I remember being on his
podcast early on where it was just in
his house and how far he's come with
that podcast is [ __ ] amazing sorry I
don't know why I was thinking of that
anyways dear Billy not so fat my
girlfriend and I have been dating for
three years going on four and I'm
starting to have different feelings
towards her because of her eating habits
in the way she takes care of herself
yeah that isn't fair to do to somebody
you know and I think it's understood
when the guy puts on weight then if a
woman comes on TV and was to talk about
that type of stuff they would side with
her for expressing herself but if a guy
does it you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] anyway
since I met her several yes your job man
you got to keep yourself looking good
you got to keep the spark going and
fifty percent of that is your
responsibility since I met her several
years ago she had cut she couldn't she
had kind of had a weight thing that was
noticeable but didn't think anything of
it because I thought she would get
on some sort of kick of wanting to lose
some weight in the years to come I
thought you're gonna say I didn't mind
because she was only a little overweight
and I liked her as a person like wow you
know I'll get her on the treadmill we
got some potential here what's funny is
that's how women look at men differently
all right he's got this job you know
maybe you'll get to this job we'll start
making that kind of money I'll get him
some new clothes I can work with this I
can fix him up and there's nothing wrong
with that you know there's nothing wrong
you know I used when I was younger used
to bother me but it doesn't bother me
that a a woman asked a guy what he does
for a living it's like what is she
supposed to do breed with a loser why
don't you like me for who I am
I you know cuz I don't want to live in a
shack all right well it's been three and
a half years and there's no stopping her
from losing weight she's 25 and I'm 30
and I don't know what to do she loves
the sweets and is not a fan of running
because it hurts her feet no boy well
get her on an elliptical um help bill
help bill I love her but I don't want to
spend my early 30s miserable in a
relationship with someone who doesn't
want to take care of herself
Thanks and go [ __ ] yourself I have to
tell you something right now dude you
are in the most difficult [ __ ]
position you can possibly be in as a man
one of the hardest [ __ ] conversations
you can have with a girlfriend
other than I'm breaking up with you is I
this is even harder because if you're
breaking up with them they're gonna cry
and then you're not gonna see him again
eventually they're gonna move on you're
gonna try to stay in a relationship
you're gonna try to tell a woman that
she needs to lose weight I gotta be
honest with you I'm like you know what
I'm gonna bring the lovely Nia on my
next podcast and we are gonna we are
going to revisit this question because I
don't know how to do this because
you know I've been I've been lucky
enough that I've always been with women
that like they you know they want to go
out and get after it or whatever you
know hit the gym or whatever I don't
know I don't I wouldn't know how to do
this because this is something this is
so [ __ ] fragile this is literally if
you start talking about a woman's weight
is in the same world as if she started
talking about your dick size or your
ability to satisfy her in the bed
because you're really talking now like a
woman won't some of that their biggest
power
a ridiculous power a woman has is her
beauty you know I know they're all out
there right now trying to act like
they're gonna start their own [ __ ]
airline and all of that [ __ ] I'm not
saying don't go do that but like you
know that is if you if you're basically
saying that you're not attracted to them
it's you know if my wife came at me and
said hey man you're getting a little bit
fat I would [ __ ] laugh and it would
so [ __ ] motivate me and to the point
I wish you would say it to me cuz I want
to tape a special soon but I gotta go
with self motivation here of thinking of
all the tweets I'm gonna get if I'm a
fat [ __ ] on my special but yeah this is
a really difficult thing don't have the
conversation until Nia comes on and even
after what Nia says I would also try to
get advice from women in your life and
you have to start it with I love my
girlfriend I love it to death we just
have a problem and I don't know how to
bring it up okay if you do that the
woman you're talking to will be more
open-minded I think to listen to you
however if you start with my
girlfriend's fat and I'm not attracted
to her what the [ __ ] they might get
defensive and start defending her and
say that you're shallow they that's
certainly going to happen on the
internet so whatever good luck with that
and I'll try to help you out on Thursday
thinking about breaking up with my
girlfriend
okay here we go dear Billy not so fat
look at this [ __ ] I got a couple of
those right wait a second oh this is the
same [ __ ] person dear my girlfriend
and I have been dating for three wait
did I just like one dude this guy's
brilliant girlfriend won't lose weight
and now thinking about breaking up with
my girlfriends from the exact same guy
dear Billy not so fat my girlfriend and
I have been dating for three years and
going on four and I'm starting to have
different feelings towards it's the
exact same [ __ ] follow this is
[ __ ] hilarious
wait a second is it it has to be it's
written a little bit different I'll
still read it since I met her several
years ago she's kind of had a weight
thing that that was noticeable but I
didn't think anything of it because I
thought she would get on some sort of
kick of mourning lose some weight years
to come well it's been three and a half
years
there's no cypher losing weight she's 25
or 30 this exact same [ __ ] guy all
right okay dude well then what I did
that's [ __ ] brilliant [ __ ]
brilliant I would say this you have to
make the decision right now do you love
your girlfriend in a way that you want
to stay with her eventually marry her
and help her through this problem or did
you sort of sort of thought you found
I'm gonna marry you love but just sort
of found love love and now that she's
overweight and you're not as attracted
to her is that feeling starting to come
up you know what I mean because that
really is that's when you find out if
you really love somebody anybody can be
around during the good times right
you're a man you're making a bunch of
money you can take her to [ __ ] you
know France or whatever you know she's a
chicken she's [ __ ] you know going to
CrossFit and crushing it and [ __ ]
looking hot that you ignore you know but
when when [ __ ]
it's the fan no cake and you have to be
there for somebody emotionally or what
are you have to accept some of their
flaws that's when you find out if you
love love somebody you know what I mean
I'm not saying that you don't think
about leave and everybody thinks about
leaving all [ __ ] time like Gia
I don't need this [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] you [ __ ] everything and I'll
[ __ ] yeah you know you know I know I
love my wife to death is even in my
fantasies when I'm mad as I can possibly
be in her even in my fantasies I can't
break up with her I get to the point
where she starts walking out of the
house and then I get sad and I run out
and hug her so there you go so there's a
good question for you and your fantasy
can you break up with somebody and you
feel all right about it no that isn't a
good litmus test because then I'm doing
the arrogant thing that you're wired
exactly the way that I am anyways
anyway I am I am back from Europe I have
to tell you that was one of the greatest
experiences I've ever had as somebody in
this business the business of show you
know trying to figure out those crowds
trying to remember how the vibe I had
the last time I was over there and it
took me a few shows of hit or misses to
figure out to fine-tune the thing like a
[ __ ] race car and I watched virzi do
it too and I'm I'm gonna call this right
now with Paul virzi that [ __ ] guy
after that said I saw him do it Gotham
and then watching him going over to
Europe nervous saying to me don't bill I
know I'm probably gonna take a couple of
[ __ ] hits over here and I would no
you're not dude you got to be fine you
gonna be fine knowing that he was that
kind of watching him figure it out to
the point that by the time we went to
Vienna the people booking it there we're
going we need to have you back we need
to have you come back here I'm just
really proud of him
because I always knew that he was going
to be able to do [ __ ] like that and his
specials crushing it and he's got a big
tour coming up and I'm gonna lose them
as an opener which is I will which is
what I want for anybody who ever opens
for me you know what I mean I never want
to have a life or opener
you know that's like having the kid that
never moved out of your house it's like
son get out there find love
alright that is it god bless all you go
[ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in on you
on Thursday hey oh by the way I think
I'm doing a podcast with that that guy
there I was telling you about
that he comes across like an old school
an old school sports announcer like a
dick schaap kind of guy way back you
know it's gonna he'd be like the best
the base of the best Patriots coverage
in the business he actually deemed me as
I started following him they William Ben
didson B and D ETS oh and where the [ __ ]
are we gonna be oh I told him sometime
around January 15th I was gonna do it
what's today today's the 14th all right
I got to reach out to this guy we're
gonna do a podcast talking Patriots and
I'll get up send out a link and all that
type of stuff hopefully because this guy
seems like he really knows the Patriots
I I don't on the other hand I mama I
watch as much as I can watch what the
travel and the kid alright anyways go
[ __ ] yourself so I'll check in on you on
Thursday see ya